jean michel a fait des vidéos il a reçu
des sms vous avez accès à tout un vrai
ce que vous avez même accès aux derniers
numéros qu'ils ont appelée puisque il ya
le numéro 7 a triché dont il ya plein de
gens qui sont en train de la plaque
alors voilà alors quand téléphone est
allumé donc vous pouvez avoir accès
c'est à dire qu'alain cayzac avec sa
femme en train de discuter vous avez le
son et l'image de votre ordinateur et
vous dit tout et notamment incroyable et
jean revéreault gens qui disent oui mais
j'ai un iphone c'est sécurisé il faut
attendre encore aujourd'hui sur 1 es13
on peut déjà ibérique et un iphone c'est
très facile alors pour être pour faire
très court
qu'est ce que j'aimerais qu'est-ce que
route le jailbreak c'est pour les iphone
le roots et pour les téléphones android
d'accord pour les personnes lambda ça
sert à quoi route et de fabriquer un
téléphone ça permet d'avoir un accès
total aux systèmes d'exploitation celui
ci ce qui signifie que vous vous frottez
votre votre iphone vous aurez accès à
des applications que vous n'aurez pas
sur l'appstore pour les personnes plus
expérimentées
ça permet de déjouer justement les
failles de sécurité que les mises à jour
d'apple et d'android fond sur la plate
forme à chaque fois d'accord alors quels
sont les trois conseils qu'on peut
donner aux téléspectateurs vous avez
donné dans un instant mais juste avant
est ce que tout le monde peut se faire
espionner son téléphone tout le monde
c'est à dire philippe tout le monde
n'importe qui c'est vraiment tout le
monde donc là je les fais dans ce cadre
là sur un téléphone android la prochaine
fois je peux vous faire sur un téléphone
iphone sans aucun problème quand même
d'accord week end vingt deux personnes
comme vous en france sont capables de
faire ça ce qu'elle n'a beaucoup alors
je dirais qu'il n'ya pas besoin d'être
aujourd'hui il ya des plateformes sur un
théâtre qui permettent de le faire il ya
pas besoin d'être un grand expert il
faut quand même se connaître un minimum
en informatique pour pouvoir voit la
route et le téléphone masqué le routage
mettre l'application là masqués dans les
fichiers système non c'est quand même
tout un petit process mais il ya des
personnes qui seraient capables de le
faire compliqué alors c'est pas si
compliqué qu'on le pense c'est compliqué
mais c'est pas si compliqué qu'on le
pense c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous
ayez votre épouse ils rentrent dormir
lui installer un logiciel de danse c'est
faisable en quelques et donc on peut la
voir avec avec jean michel maire après
21 éventuellement c'est incroyable
justice sur les sur les sms
même quand ils sont supprimés aussi on
peut les avoir derrière abbas si on a
réussi à avoir les photos on peut avoir
les sms les appels
whatsapp ah mais c'est pareil c'est la
même joie de sa peau si vous avez tissé
exactement une chose hélas si vous
regardez mon logiciel jeu peut même voir
télégramme les échanges qui sont pas
cryptés sur télé verwee ça veut dire
vous avez tout tout tout tout tout
totalité donc l'air très inquiet non
mais juste de vérifier seront sur
téléphone et a été infectée comment peut
on faire quand on peut faire tous fait
appel à des sociétés de sécurité
informatique mais même là ce sera
difficile pour eux et essien le bar
regard des moines jean michel maire moi
je peux essayer de le trouver mais
demande à jean michel maire de ria les
téléphones de zapper de cieux dedans il
va rien y trouver de suspect d'accord
lors d'un gardien dubeau vais pas le
voir comme ça il faut vraiment rire
indique cinq visites bas sinon c'est
inutile ça ne s'est pas lisible bah
c'est invisible parce que si c'était
visible ça servira à rien si votre
épouse ou quelqu'un qu'on espionne voix
qui l'espionnaient il n'y a pas
d'utilité disponibles ce qui va
supprimer l'application directement ou
changer de téléphone alors dans un
instant vous allez me donner trois
conseils pour éviter l'espionnage des
données aux téléspectateurs ça on attend
ça avec impatience que là on est tous en
train de fibres et surtout isabelle
parce que oui il ya des photos du cap
nuls dans sont-elles id riche et expert
en informatique et depuis le début il
vous fait flipper crise et sa fille
idriss on a donné un téléphone à
jean-michel ça dépasse au téléphone mais
c'est un téléphone voilà que vous avez
infesté exactement intégré exactement
expo n'est exactement certains refusent
jean michel a fait des vidéos il a reçu
des sms vous avez accès à tout un vrai
ce que vous avez même accès aux derniers
numéros qu'ils ont appelée puisque il ya
le numéro 7 a triché dont il ya plein de
gens qui sont en train de la plaque
alors voilà alors l'appelez pas ce n'est
pas numéro d'aujourd'hui c'est un numéro
comme ça c'est le numéro que j'aime
énormément dans la carte sim aussi
d'accord fusée là pour moi je peux pas
excédé la cité bloqué parce que
tellement de d'internautes qui essayent
de rentrer dedans mais j'ai entendu un
mot de passe qui pourront rien faire
moi ce que les conseil que je pourrais
donner pour éviter justement tenter
d'éviter que ça se produise sur un
nouveau portable
quant au reste des conseils basiques
parce que ça pourra toujours se produire
on va pas se mentir
mais bon quand même les deux trois trucs
qu'il faut pas faire du tout vous les
hauts risques
oui prenez un nokia 32 10 avec aussi
pensez pas 32 10
alain 1110 avec la petite antenne non
cela vous aurait pas de problème de
piratage 5110 enat alem l'acheter c'est
le genre de nommer les choses c'est vrai
nom mais c'est le genre de téléphones
qui utilisent les dealers tout
simplement pour pas être localisé
précisément et sont localisées avec des
bornes téléphoniques donc ya pas de
localisation de ces accords et même le
32 10 il est dangereux
oui est-ce qu'on peut infecter le
serpent mais sa vraie merveille mon nom
mais réellement iliad il ya certains
anciens modèles de téléphones qui sont
un filtre à bhl et d'autres non d'accord
le 51 filtrables c'est le dock et aqua
50 51 10 et tous les vieux modèles qu'on
les petites antennes saeco
ericsson tout ça certains ericsson et
samsung bale et sam sont via les
nouveaux samsung et les anciens donc ça
dépend vraiment des taureaux lala le cas
avec le clapet là comme ça ah bah ça
aussi c'est parfait c'est parfait ça va
moi c'est le touriste ou là le stade
j'adore et bah tiens je vais prendre un
start après si vous voulez rester
vraiment à la mode et avoir un téléphone
chaude pas envie de moi tout le monde a
envie d'avoir mois de sa part envie
d'avoir un sélectionneur est à la mode
on la revoit ce book vous prenez vous
êtes fous de votre téléphone est
faillible se faisait la mode vos
téléphones est faillible très clairement
mais après donc les petits conseils
comme je vous ai dit pour que j'avais
déjà expliqué lors de la dernière
émission je vous en donner d'autres par
exemple mais son téléphone à jour donc
la version ios ou android ça peut
paraître un peu bizarre pour certaines
personnes c'est très facile il suffit
d'aller dans les réglages et de faire
une mise à jour du logiciel
ça permettra provisoirement de ne pas
être piratées jusqu'à ce que la nouvelle
faille sorte parce qu'il faut savoir que
le premier android et le premier iphone
ils sont sortis en 2007
on est aujourd'hui en 2020 ça fait 13
ans ils font des mises à jour ils ont
des dizaines de milliers d'experts en
sécurité informatique et ça jamais été
aussi faillible que ça l'est aujourd'hui
enfin que franchement il ya moi où je me
dis je vous donne des petites clés mais
y'a pas d'astuce magique ça n'existe pas
il ya quoi d'autre sinon quand vous
téléchargez une application par exemple
vous avez téléchargé chroniqueur kandic
roddick à bientôt j'ai fait constitue ce
moment là c'est ça vous des fois vous
télécharger des applications sur le sur
le ps store
et puis on vous demande d'accéder de
pouvoir autoriser vous accédez à vos
appels à vos sms à votre localisation
alors que ce n'est pas forcément utile
leur 10,3 allez-vous faire en lex bas
vous mettez refuser tout simplement les
gens mettent tous autorisés parce qu'ils
disent non application ne va pas
s'installer
vous mettez refuse et refusera refusez
vous installez un logiciel type coyote
ou gps c'est normal qu'on vous demande
d'accès à votre localisation dans ce cas
il faut l'accepter d'année surtout ne
pas autoriser les accès ou voilà tout ce
qui sur l'e mail
est-ce qu'il faut ouvrir il faut pas
ouvrir les mêmes parce qu'il ya plein de
mails de voyance aussi court soit par
exemple syrie le mois je reçois souvent
cyril il faut que je te dise une
personne autour de toi et là ils mettent
trois petits points et tu dois aller
cliquer sur la mention la peau enfin
pour moi ça me paraît logique de ne pas
cliquer alors pour un excédent lambda je
me doute que ça peut être compliqué ed
aussi vous avez gagné une audi a8 à une
dizaine mais c'est vrai et vous
dites-vous n'est gagné au loto qui avait
gagné j'ai pas son héritage
quoique ce soit que vous envoyez votre
tri pour pouvoir récupérer au fond ça
ouais toutes les âneries enfin ça c'est
des techniques typiquement congolaise ou
sénégalaise apte à grandir et où il m'a
envoyé moi agrandir le pénis à web à toi
je sais que tu l'as fait alors
heureusement ça n'a pas marché c'est
pour ça qu'il est privé elle abat des
faux mails qui proviennent de partout
c'est vers soi orange et m6 ou encore
rien nous et vous dites que si les mms
ou moi je vais vous dire une chose les
multinationales et les grosses boîtes
comme la vôtre par exemple ou comme
n'importe quel autre
elles sont le plus faible pas par le
biais des directeurs mais par le biais
des employés cirque c'est surtout les
employés qui font des erreurs et cliquer
sur des liens en donnant des mots de
passe qui donne ensuite accès à d'autres
systèmes etc etc pour remonter et
piratage sur ses jambes et sa tête